bon maintenant c'est vous richard qu'ils
allaient descendre aux enfers
on va faire un blindtest télé réalité un
blind test de merde je suis saint pascal
bravo je dois dire que ça fait des
années que j'ai pas regardé ce site on
veut justement c'est pour ça qu'on te
fait sinon toi tu vois tu assures alors
dit didier et l'hiver pour un mec bien
lutte contre la téléréalité animée
connais tous attention d'idées
sow
ils ont tous
et
6e
bah oui vous savez qui c'est à weight
watchers bravo exactement cette
attention
didier
un mois
à l'aise les l5 bravo cette fois du bois
coupé c'est toi tu connais ses larmes
que message que sur l'attitude attention
didier
m
emma dommages graves connaît bien quand
même non c'est les plus connus parce que
j'écoute la radio je vais pas pouvoir
retourner à toulouse moi je pense alors
sonné la samba ce que c'est
c'est une reprise de d'une chanson des
années 80 mais je me suis surprise de
phil barney pigeons et la pie qui chante
s'appelle non mais vous c'est normal
merci didier
à vivendi donc il a fallu pas mal quand
même assez content de moi finalement
finalement très content que pas pouvoir
retourner à toulouse moi je pense
richard sénécal
c'est oublier ses pleins d'arrière
mesdames messieurs